The U.S.
military has
shot down another high altitude
this time over Lake Huron.
This is according to a U.S.
official and a congressional sou
briefed on the matter.
This would be the fourth
object brought down by U.S.
fighter jets in the past nine da
CNN's Colby
Atwood is at the State Departmen
Kylie, what are you learning?
Yeah, that's right, Paula.
And the third object brought dow
just the last three days, of cou
We're learning
that this high altitude
object was traveling and shot do
Lake Huron,
which is north of Michigan,
in between Michigan and Canada,
right up there.
That is according to a U.S. offi
And a congressional source
briefed on the matter.
It appears that members of Congr
from Michigan
are learning more about this
in conversations with the Pentag
I want to read to
what Congresswoman Slotkin tweet
just in the last 2 hours
or so, saying, quote,
The object has been down by pilo
from the U.S.
Air Force and National Guard.
Great work by all
who carried out this mission,
both in the air and back at head
We're all interested in exactly
what this object was and its pur
We're also hearing
from other members
of Congress from Michigan,
Congressman Bergman
saying that he is appreciative
of what he's calling
the decisive action
of the fighter pilots here.
So there's a lot more to learn a
you know,
just what exactly this object wa
I think
our let our colleague
is getting some more colleagues
from her sources on that.
But it's notable that this was a
something that the United States
was able to track
potentially in part because Noor
the last week
adjusted its controls to better
slow moving objects at high alti
So what they were able to do
is put into place
these FAA temporary flight restr
into spaces
where they were seeing
potentially an object come throu
The question remains an open
one as to
if there are more objects
coming into US airspace now
or if these adjustments
are just allowing them to detect
At a higher rate Paula.
Kelly, I would thank you.
And CNN's Paula Newton joins us
Paula, what are the Canadian
officials saying about this?
Yeah, well, suffice it
to say that
Canadian officials are obviously
also keeping a close eye on any
altitude objects,
as you say, that no unauthorized
has been surveilling.
I mean, look, at Lake Huron
basically cuts
across both the US
and Canadian territories.
And for that reason,
leaders on both sides,
both President
Biden and Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau, would have been kept
informed of
what was going on with this obje
Now, when I asked Canadian offic
they referred me to narrate,
which was responsible for this o
but defense officials in Canada
did promise to get back to us
with more information
about exactly what went on there
I will note that Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau is en route to Yu
A complete
coincidence Paula, in terms of h
being there the day after
Canada ordered that high altitud
to be shot down in Yukon.
What's interesting
here, though, was when Prime Min
Justin Trudeau
spoke this morning before that t
he did say that they felt
that this was a threat to civil
And that's why he thought
that the object
had to come down as soon as poss
unlike those objects
that they
perhaps had been surveilling for
The other thing that was interes
was that
that object over Yukon,
they had had
been surveilling it
for at least a day
before they actually shot it dow
What will be interesting
here, Paula, is to note exactly
when they detected this object,
was it also coming through
that northern part from Canada
or did it
float in from somewhere else
over the Great Lakes, perhaps?
Still a lot of questions.
Again, Canadian officials
promise to get back to us.
But right now,
they are deferring questions to
which they say
took the lead on this operation
after getting the order from U.S
President Joe Biden.
Carly, the Pentagon is now
addressing this incident.
What are you learning?
Yeah, the Pentagon
press office telling reporters
just in the last few minutes
here, Paula,
that this object was shot down o
Lake Huron at 2:42 p.m.
this afternoon
at the direction of President Bi
by F-16
fighter jets
They're saying that
it didn't pose
a military threat,
but it did potentially pose
a threat to civilian aircraft.
And that is because it was trave
according to this statement,
at about 20,000 feet elevation.
Now, when you think about
every day, air
aircraft, they fly at about 37,0
So this statement says
that the Biden administration, U
officials were concerned
about the path
that this was following
up, that this was traveling on,
and also that elevation.
Now, when it comes to any risk
to civilians,
there wasn't any
there were no civilians who were
or injured. Or otherwise affecte
Of course, being shot down over
water enabled that to be an outc
And we should note that yesterda
there were some questions about
an FAA temporary flight restrict
put into place in Montana.
And there were some questions
about what
actually triggered
that flight restriction.
We didn't get a definitive answe
on that today.
There were a number of differing
that we heard.
But with this statement from the
says is that
they believe
that this object
is what actually triggered
that flight restriction yesterda
And I just want to read
to exactly what they say
here, saying, quote,
Based on its flight path and dat
we can reasonably connect
this object to the radar
signal picked up over Montana,
which flew in proximity
to sensitive DOD sites.
We did not assess it
to be a kinetic military threat
to anything on the ground,
but assess it was a safety fligh
and a threat due
to its potential surveillance ca
Is now surveillance capabilities
The potential for those is key h
So far,
we don't know
what those capabilities on board
this unidentifiable object actua
But that, rest assured,
is going to be something
that those
who are doing these recovery eff
which is now going to be getting
are going to be looking
for answers to Paula.
Carly, I would thank you.
And Republican
Congressman Chuck
program of Michigan joins us now
Representative, you serve on the
Armed Services Committee.
What is your reaction
to what the Pentagon
just revealed,
the take down of this
object near Lake Huron
Well, my reaction is very simple
and that is
when the Pentagon called me shor
after it took action
because Lake Huron in that area
is in my district
number one, decisive action.
Using the right equipment, the F
using the right type of munition
to do the takedown
but now the big part,
as was mentioned by my colleague
a minute ago,
is the recovery piece
to understand that Lake Huron is
very cold this time of year.
They're going to have to use
some special diving
capabilities to get down there.
The good news is Lake
Huron is not that deep,
not like Lake Superior, but the
to take decisive action
by Northern Command,
the Department of Defense is wha
because we've seen it
over the past few weeks
There are some
challenges to our sovereign airs
And this is the third object sho
just three days.
How concerned are you about this
Okay.
I just lost your audio it.
Try one more time.
Sure thing.
This is the third object shot do
just three days.
How can it seems like we've lost
the congressman.
We will go to our expert panel
and try to circle back
with Congressman Jack Bertram.
All right.
Let's talk
more about this with CNN
military analyst, retired U.S.
Air Force Colonel Cedric
Leighton
and CNN national security analys
Juliette Kayyem.
Colonel Leighton.
Juliette,
thank you so much for being with
I want to get your reaction
to what we just heard from the P
Juliette, I want to start with y
Yeah,
so it's just a confirmation
of what we have been reporting,
which is essentially we
we still don't know what the obj
I think what's really important
the military is is acknowledging
that they are getting lots
of positives now
because after what happened
with the Chinese balloon,
they are now opening up the aper
They're getting more positives.
They are
then assessing what it is in the
if it is unmanned.
If it is a threat to commercial
And if shooting it down
is not going to harm Americans.
Basically,
the assumption is we're shooting
down at this stage
until we figure out what this is
It does
not mean we know it's the Chines
it does not mean
that it's simply these
these potential positives,
because as we're looking harder
after what happened
with the Chinese balloon
and I think we should just antic
that at this stage until we can
what it is that they're finding
once they shoot it down.
And that
and I think
any other speculation
could be very dangerous
for our relations and could hone
harm Americans
because we
will be so convinced
that this is an enemy,
that these are enemy balloons
or whatever they are that we wil
We could potentially make calcul
that do not fit the risk at this
So that's sort of where we are r
And I anticipate
we are going to get more of thes
at this stage.
So great point.
Colonel Leighton,
what's your reaction
to this latest development
from the Pentagon?
Yeah, I think, you know, as Juli
said this to confirm a lot of wh
previously have been talking abo
One of the key
things I thought was very intere
was the fact that they mentioned
that the surveillance part of th
was a definite possibility.
So this seems to lend
credence to the idea that these
fact, surveillance
aircraft of whatever type.
And I think we should treat them
as such until we know much more.
And that means we're
taking security measures
at our bases
that are other government situat
And even if we're personnel,
you know, people in the civilian
to be
somewhat cognizant of the possib
that cell phone conversations
could be intercepted
by the Chinese,
they're already being intercepte
in many cases anyways.
But it's just one of those thing
that part of the new reality
and it you know,
these devices can in some ways
make that even more of a plausib
to people that are both normal p
civilians and people who
are in government service.